i like analogies you know me right so
that's why i made that video was fun i
was thinking about this
i was coming out of a meeting where i
was proud of myself
which happens often with the way i feel
about myself
but something happened where it really
worked out for vayner
and i was just so happy again because
everything on paper said that we should
have worried about
x y and z and i didn't and it really
worked it just reminded me again
god dammit people are spending too much
time worrying about the things that
don't matter
one percent of the things that are
happening in your business matter
one one and like like now i don't know
how to like teach
i'm not good at teaching what that one
percentage if i worked if i joined your
business i'd tell you in two minutes
right six weeks then i'd have it it's
why vayner works because i think i'm
good
for the businesses we work in forget the
social i think i know how to
run their businesses better um so
that's what that meant what i've learned
after having a second child is
we're not micromanaging every little
thing that we did with the first driving
xander's walk i mean xander's like on
the street we're like cool
you good ex good you know like misha
couldn't like go one step
like i mean you know we like she would
sleep and we'd look at her face for an
hour
right so um i mean i went into misha's
room
700 times in the first couple years so
just making sure she was breathing right
like you just get scared it's just like
intense love with business i was mature
already with
wine library back to the baseball card
stuff i knew and i'm just trying to help
young entrepreneurs to just like
take a step back and realize like okay
like i'm always telling my team like
okay end good they'll fire us we're
still rolling
we're plenty to do business i care more
about your feelings don't get too
pressured like
so i just i'm just trying to figure out
you know i'm always taking stabs
i'm trying to tell a story in a certain
way that might hit home that one was
actually directed towards a little bit
of an older crowd
because they have had two children and
they know exactly what i'm talking about
because the first child you know like
was perfect the second one's like
eating dirt outside while you're inside
right and so
that's you know obviously when you go
through it your first time you don't
have that context
of what that is but you're gaining
context right away one year into your
business you can look back
at all the things you worried about that
weren't that serious try to imply
the past into future decisions